>> This piece was on Google in the New Yorker
and I worked with him -- I talked with him
extensively about that piece and we've become
good friends ever after.
And that was ten years ago, I think, that
piece.
It's kind of incredible how time flies.
Anyhow, I'm excited to welcome him back to
Google.
He's obviously visited many times.
But now, he's visiting us as the person we
get to interview.
So the roles are a little bit reversed.
And I'm excited to welcome him to talk about
his new book about 'Denialism'.
And then we get to grill him and, just like
ten years ago, you got to torture me.
Now, I get my revenge.
So welcome, Michael.
Please come on up and talk.
>> [Clapping]
Michael Specter: First time I came here, there
were less than a hundred employees.
So it's kind of -- every time I come here
now, I get lost in more and more creative
ways, including today.
I just want to talk about my book and the
themes in it for a little bit.
And then there will be questions, I'm sure,
and I'll be happy to answer them.
The name of the book is Denialism, and immediately
people wonder what I mean by that.
I think we've all been in denial at one point
in our lives.
Something bad happens; we can't deal with
it.
It's kind of normal.
It might even be good for a little while on
an individual level.
It's extremely harmful when it lasts.
And it's very deleterious to society when
we do this in an institutional way.
And I think that's what's happening in a whole
number of areas of life these days.
And I'll talk about that.
I should also first say what I didn't write
about, because that seems to interest people
too.
I didn't write about climate change and I
didn't write about creationism -- both of
which are truly denialist issues.
And why didn't I?
I went down to the Creation Museum in Kentucky
-- which I urge you all to do -- and I kind
of ended up feeling that, if somebody wants
to believe that their ancestors rode around
on dinosaurs, there's nothing I can do to
have a conversation with them that will be
of value to either one of us.
With climate change, I just felt that the
preponderance of evidence is so powerful that
-- so many people have written so convincingly.
There's so much documentation -- that for
me to add a chapter about it would be kind
of like putting a feather on a mountaintop.
So, while I do address those issues in the
book, they're not the things I focus on.
I try to focus on things that are possibly
more daily-life activities, and lately in
the news, and that wasn't on purpose, but
one of them is vaccines.
And this is an area of life that I can never
stop being mystified by, because vaccines
are the most effective public health measure
in the history of the world except for clean
water -- no debate, no argument.
41 percent of Americans say they won't take
the H1N1 flu shot or give it to their kids.
To me, this is mind blowing.
So far, 11 million doses of this vaccine have
been administered.
And I think there have been reports of two
or three serious side effects -- and that
will happen.
If 11 million people drink water, there will
be a side effect.
I mean, this is the thing that people don't
ever -- you never look at the other side.
Five thousand people have died so far from
this flu -- five hundred kids.
Thousands more will die.
So when you do the math -- and people almost
never do -- it's not really a difficult equation.
But part of denialism is that people don't
do the math.
They feel comfortable in their own intuition,
in what they think is evidence, in their own
anecdotal experience -- and it almost never
works.
I was at a party a week ago, and a pregnant
woman came up to me, and said -- I had written
a story in the New Yorker, just a little thing
about the flu -- and she said, "Oh, you're
the flu guy."
Which, believe me, I've been called worse.
I said, "Yes?" She said, "Well, I'm not going
to get that vaccine."
And I said, "Well, that's good.
Because you're exactly the person who should
be getting it.
So that makes perfect sense."
I said, "Why aren't you getting it?" She said,
"Well, I feel fine."
[laughter] And you know, you don't feel pregnant
until you get pregnant either.
I mean, these things can't be stopped.
And I tried to talk to her and tell her that
viruses don't care if you feel fine now, but
it wasn't going to happen.
Then, I got an e-mail the next day which was
more disturbing to me.
It was from a college classmate of mine who
had heard me on a radio station or something.
And she said that some of what I wrote about
she agreed with, but she certainly wasn't
vaccinating her child against polio, because
'we don't have polio'. Cool.
You know, the longest flight in the world
is shorter than the shortest incubation time
for an infectious disease.
And polio exists in the world.
So, what does that mean?
If somebody in Nigeria gets on a plane -- doesn't
know he has polio, but certainly could, because
it's there -- flies to say here, goes to Google
for an interview, you can get infected.
That hasn't happened. Maybe it won't happen.
It would be great if it didn't, but it's insane
to believe that it couldn't happen.
And to walk away from what is really a miraculous
scientific advance, but people do it all the
time.
And it really -- it never ceases to amaze
me.
But I'm beginning to think it's fear, and
fear is just as infectious as any other virus.
And people are afraid of what they hear.
They're afraid of autism with vaccines.
And it doesn't matter that there have been
3 million kids studied to see whether autism
is related to measles vaccines.
And that's kind of a study you can do pretty
well, because there's a lot of kids that have
been vaccinated and a lot of kids who haven't.
And if you look at the rate at which autism
develops, you'll see it's the same progression
in either case.
So how that could happen, I don't know. Is
that?
What are we looking at? [laughter] Is that
competition or what?
Anyway. Cool. I love -- I like technology.
Okay. [laughter]
>> Sorry about that.
Michael Specter: Sergey, you're gone, right?
Okay, cool.
I look at these issues and I just wonder what
people are thinking.
And I know some of what people are thinking
makes sense.
We don't have measles in this country.
People don't know what measles is.
They don't know what polio is.
They don't know what smallpox is.
Smallpox is gone from the world, but it killed
billions of people not that long ago.
I mean, these diseases were in this country
not two generations ago but one generation
ago.
And the idea that they could never come back
-- I'm hoping that smallpox won't come back,
because if it does, someone's making it in
a laboratory.
We can get that later -- people are just anxious
about what they don't know, and they don't
do any sort of rational thinking about things
that affect them personally.
And I find this very clearly in another area
that I write about that I think may be dear
to many people's heart in this area, which
is food.
The fight over organic food and genetically
engineered food is the stupidest, most ridiculous,
culture war that exists in this country.
It is of absolutely no -- there's no reason
to have it.
All food we eat is genetically modified food.
They didn't have cantaloupes or tangerines
in the Garden of Eden.
Over time, we have bred both animals and plants
to do the things that we want them to do.
Now, genetic engineering isn't more powerful
technology, and the idea that it's just the
same as anything else is kind of silly and
wrong.
And there are lots of problems with genetically-engineered
food, and you're probably aware with some
of them, but what are they?
One is monoculture, just like one crop taking
over a huge area.
Another is heavy use of pesticide.
Synthetic chemicals.
Those things are very serious and severe,
and they have kind of nothing to do with genetically-engineered
crops.
They have a lot to do with the way those crops
are treated.
All this stuff happened with conventional
crops before these crops came along.
When people start yelling at me about organic
food, what they often seem to be yelling about
in the end is multinational corporations,
deadlocks on patents on seeds, things that
you don't think are fair, like owning parts
of nature.
And I think all that is completely legitimate,
and we should have conversations about it.
And there are amazingly effective ways to
prevent that from happening in the future.
But it isn't the science. Science isn't a
company.
Science isn't Monsanto. Science is science.
And it has worked really well since the Enlightenment
at least.
It has brought us so far.
A kid born in Bangladesh today lives longer
than a rich man who was born in Park Avenue
a hundred years ago.
That, to me, is an amazing fact.
And it isn't a coincidence. It's because of
the tools we have.
And when people say, "Genetically-engineered
food shouldn't be used at all."
You know, a billion people go to bed hungry
every night in this world?
A billion.
And in 40 years, we're going to need 70 percent
more food than we have right now.
So, you guys are mathematically more gifted
than me, but it seems to me there's two ways
to get more food.
You can grow more on the land that you have,
or you can use more land.
If we use much more land, we're basically
cutting down even more rain forest than we've
already destroyed, and I don't really think
that's an approach.
Getting more, as they say, 'crop per drop'
is an approach, and it is a solution.
It is not the magic solution.
But, you know, you can eat vine-ripened tomatoes.
I just had a fantastic meal here.
It's great, but we're not in sub-Saharan Africa.
Hundreds of millions of people in the world
subsist on cassava.
I don't know if you guys know -- it's just
a bunch of carbohydrates.
It has no protein. It has no micronutrients.
It's not something you can live on.
So genetic engineers have decided to engineer
all the stuff you need to live on into cassava
-- vitamin A, micronutrients, protein -- and
it's working.
It's happening. And it's not planted yet.
And when they get done, there will be field
trials.
But the idea that we can do this in parts
of the world that have nothing else.
You know, that might not be the tastiest food
in the world, but it's going to keep them
alive and it's going to make them better.
And for us to say, "This is bad" -- especially
for reasons that kind of don't exist -- it
makes me, as you might sense, kind of crazy
and mad.
I just don't like to see this become an ideological
war, and I think it really has.
Now, there are some legitimate reasons for
that.
I think genetically engineered food kind of
got unleashed on the world without anyone
ever talking about it.
And people tend to say the thing I just said.
It can do miraculous things, but what does
it really do these days?
You know, so we can factory-feed animals,
shoot them with hormones, and make them sick
and make ourselves sick.
It's not a pretty picture.
It doesn't have to be that way just because
it is that way.
You know the car industry in the United States
sucks.
It's terrible.
Should we not have cars? Or should we make
them better?
Should we use fuel that's clean?
I kind of think we can do that. We're already
doing it.
We need to do it more and better and we can.
But to walk away from science and agriculture
when so many people really cling to it, is
something that -- it worries me as it worries
me when we walk into a vitamin store and we
buy tons of vitamins.
We swallow 20 vitamins a day.
We drink antioxidant formulas and elixirs
and potions and pills.
And almost none of this is of any value whatsoever.
It's, if you want dark, you're in. It's great.
And there are vitamins that are important
-- vitamin D, vitamin B sometimes, folic
acid for pregnant women -- but most of the
stuff that you see in your vitamin store could
be put in a giant bag and thrown into the
ocean and the only bad thing about that would
be that it would pollute the ocean, because
it's of no value.
So why do we do that?
Well, I don't think it's actually totally
for stupid reasons, though I think the effect
is really damaging.
Our health care system is a disaster; it costs
too much.
Even those of us who are insured don't really
get what we ought to get.
People don't like pharmaceutical corporations
sometimes for good reason.
They charge too much; they're predatory.
Our doctors seem to be distant, remote, and
cold.
Things are bad.
So you go into a vitamin store and everything
seems natural.
And they say it's natural and all the support
your cardiovascular health and your eyes.
They sell a lot of vitamins that have vitamin
A and it'll support your good vision.
You need vitamin A; it's really important.
There is no person in the United States that
has a vitamin A deficiency.
We don't have that problem here.
We have the "too much calories, eat fat, and
hormones" problem.
So yes, in the developing world, we need to
deal with that, but we don't need to buy it
in, you know, the vitamin advisor across the
street.
But you see it over and over again.
And I understand -- it's a reaction to something
that is genuinely troubling.
But what are we getting when we get those
vitamins?
We think they're natural?
I mean, do you know who makes those vitamins?
How they're regulated? What's in them? No
you don't.
Do you think those people -- we spent $28
billion on it last year.
You think those corporations didn't want to
make money?
They're doing it just because they want you
to feel good, whereas Merck wants you to die?
I mean, when I talk about this on the radio,
that seems to be the supposition.
And I did write -- the first chapter of my
book is on Vioxx, which was a nonsteroidal
antiinflammatory -- and I wrote it for two
reasons.
One is, I want people to realize that I'm
quite aware that there are legitimate reasons
for mistrusting authority in this country.
And the other is a more complicated reason,
which I'll discuss.
Vioxx was a drug that people took for arthritis.
And it was -- at the time of its introduction
-- seen as miraculous.
Aspirin works, up to a point, but causes tremendous
gastrointestinal distress.
Advil, the same. People have even died from
it.
It's difficult to live a life where you're
taking 40 aspirin a day.
Vioxx seemed to circumvent that problem.
And it was, you know -- you couldn't turn
on a television set without seeing an ad.
You couldn't open a magazine.
It was the most heavily-marketed drug in the
history of the United States until the little
blue pill came along.
And you know Viagra dwarfs it in all ways.
But it turned out that the miracle wasn't
so fabulous, because people started dropping
dead of heart attacks.
And, in the end, 55,000 Americans -- that's
an FDA estimate.
It could be more or less -- died as a result
of taking Vioxx.
And the drug was withdrawn, as you would expect
that it would be.
And Merck knew this; they knew there were
cardiovascular risks.
They didn't go out and warn people, and it's
shameful.
It's horrible what happened. There's no excuse
for it.
But having said that, I'll say another thing.
Why is Vioxx off the market?
I mean, should it be off the market?
Because millions of people had a tremendous
benefit from that drug.
And its flaws were very easy for a doctor
to notice.
You're obese, you have diabetes, you have
cholesterol problems, you have a history of
heart disease -- these are things that you
can know -- you yourself, your physician.
There's no reason that a drug like that can't
be prescribed in the right way.
Actually, there is a reason, because in this
country, once a drug is approved by the Food
and Drug Administration, you can do whatever
you want with it.
You can call it a chair and sell it as furniture.
I mean, it's ridiculous. And so, that's a
problem.
And given that situation, the thing to do
is get rid of drugs like that.
But I do believe that we shouldn't be in a
country where you can't use things effectively
and intelligently.
And that's what the move to genomics is about.
But it's a slow transition.
And people don't think about the other side.
You know, if we regulated cars the way we
regulated drugs, then no one in this country
would be allowed to enter a car.
Absolutely no one.
Not only that, we kill tens of thousands of
people in cars every year.
We know that we do that.
If we even lowered the speed limit by ten
miles, we would save five to eight thousand
lives a year. Totally known fact.
But we want to get to the mall. And that's
more important.
So the idea that, "Yeah, we can kill them
in cars. That's fine.
Because we want to go somewhere.
But we won't take any risk with the drug.
If a drug kills four people, it ought to be
yanked off the market."
It's kind of a crazy way to think.
If every American took two aspirin right now
-- I don't know -- three, five hundred of
us would be dead by dinner.
Does that mean -- I think 19 billion aspirin
were swallowed last year.
Should we not have aspirin?
I think it's a great drug.
I think it's helped billions of people.
We should have it, but there are risks.
And there are risks to every single thing
you do in the world.
And people don't want to think that way.
And that's one of the vaccine issues.
You don't see measles.
You just see a needle coming in, and so you
think, "Oh, my baby.
And I've heard this stuff."
And it is a little daunting.
But I don't -- you know, I talk to someone
who said, "It's just that I don't want to
put a foreign substance in my body."
I mean, what do you think she does at dinner
every night?
Those are foreign substances. It's no different.
But people don't think that way.
And they also are suspicious of authority.
And I understand that, but we need to get
beyond that.
And I think we kind of need to get beyond
that in a hurry.
And the way that we can do that, I think,
is to look ahead.
And if we look at personal genomics, if we
look at synthetic biology -- and I've wrote
about those in the book.
Synthetic biology, in particular, seems to
me to be an area where we can do something
we didn't do with genetically engineered food,
which is, have a conversation.
I think one of the big problems with genetically
engineered food and organic food is there
are these screaming sides and nobody actually
thinks about what they're saying.
Synthetic biology can do a lot of things.
It already has.
We've made fake versions of Artemisinin, which
is the most important malaria drug.
And we'll be able to make all the malaria
medication we need in the world in one vat
in one factory and it'll be cheap and it'll
be off-patent and accessible.
It's developed by Jay Keasling in Berkeley,
and it is going to be an amazing thing.
Because right now, they grow it in Africa.
They grow it in Asia.
It's a question of whether farming, the health
of the farmers, you know, you're dependent
on the sun and the rain and the wells.
This is terrific, but there are also risks.
And we're doing this with other things.
We're doing it with energy sources.
We're going to be able to make diesel and
other fuel that can theoretically -- and actually,
in real life now -- power cars without emissions
that are the things that we try so hard to
avoid and yet never do.
I think this is a really exciting way to deal
with climate change.
And I think we're going to have to employ
it.
It doesn't mean that we're going to solve
our problems -- with that or any single technology
or solve our food problems with one technology.
But we need it.
We need science to help us.
And I think the only way that people are going
to accept this in this country is to talk
about it now, because it's scary.
It is actually scary.
When you start making fake organisms out of
chemicals, then all that Dr. Frankenstein
stuff is actually real -- and it is.
I wrote a piece for the New Yorker a year
and a half ago about some scientists who were
taking extinct retroviruses that had been
extinct for, in some cases, hundreds of thousands
of years, and sort of stitching them back
together and bringing them back to life.
And people responded to this not in a happy
way.
Why would you do that?
Well, there's a guy in New York, Eckard Wimmer,
who bought polio.
He made polio out of synthetic chemicals and
was hated for it.
And I trashed him in the story.
And he called me up and said, "You don't know
what you're talking about.
You're totally wrong."
Which does actually sometimes happen.
So I went up and saw him.
I spent a day with him.
And he was completely right.
Because what was he doing by making fake polio?
He was putting the constituent parts together
so you can make rapid vaccines against -- we're
trying to learn how to make vaccines that
you don't -- what we do now is we grow vaccines
in eggs.
That's exactly the same thing we did after
World War II.
I mean we have wifi here, except for some
of this technology works really well.
We shouldn't be growing vaccines in eggs in
Pennsylvania and hoping that things turn out
okay, but we are.
And what Wimmer is doing and what a lot of
people are doing is saying, "Let's get the
constituent parts.
We know what the molecules are.
We know what the proteins are.
Let's put them together so we can take them
apart.
Let's figure out ways to disable them."
And that's really exciting, but it's also
genuinely scary, because once you start making
things -- to take a dead virus and make it
infectious after two hundred years is not
a minor thing.
And I think scientists sometimes are guilty
of saying, "Hey, this is science.
Let's just do it."
What, are you an idiot?
And you know, people need to step back and
talk about this.
I say in my book -- and people call me utopian
for this -- "We should have a national conversation
about this in the president of the United
States should lead it."
He has town meetings about the economic crisis
and the economic crisis is real.
But the future of our planet isn't real?
I mean, these are very serious issues, very
serious theoretical solutions, and high risks.
And I think we should sit down and say, "Are
the risks worth it?
What are the benefits?
How much does it cost?
What do we need to do?" We never have those
conversations in this country.
We just sort of go ahead.
And often that's worked, that they just went
ahead with trains and that Internet thing
and it just showed up.
But I think we're at a point now where we
really are doing something that makes people
uneasy.
And I don't think the answer to that is not
to do it.
I think it's to explain it.
And I think, when things aren't explained
properly, what you have is denialism.
You have people hiding in their own wishes,
superstitions, what makes them feel comfortable.
And usually what makes you feel comfortable
isn't actually the thing you want to do, down
the road.
So I just like people to be a little thoughtful
about -- not just themselves -- but other
people.
You know, when you get a vaccine and you don't
get it?
It's not just you.
It's not just your kid.
It's the people who go to school with your
kid.
And it's understandable to be afraid, but
you need to also look at the other side.
And we just so rarely do in this country.
We so rarely think that something is anything
other than a plot that it's really getting
kind of scary.
And I think we're getting away from who we
are.
And Google is the representation of who we
I mean, we can do amazing things.
And we don't want to walk away from our ability
to do that, because we're afraid of science.
And that has happened I think.
Anyway, that's my thing.
People can question me if they want.
I'm sure that others might have different
views and I'd love to hear them.
So thank you.
>> [Clapping]
Michael Specter: Everyone agrees to everything
I said.
This is first time in recorded history that
that that's happened.
All right. Good. Bummer.
Q If I could ask a question. Does this work?
So you mentioned it would be great if Obama
would lead a cover station on a more rational
way to deal with this country.
My concern is there's a political system that
would immediately spring to force to try to
counter anything.
How do we finesse the politics to get the
conversation going?
Michael Specter: I mean, you know, it's a
good question.
And this is not a minor thing, but we do have
a president now who -- I don't want to make
him into more than he is, but he's appointed
some really good people and scientists to
run the agencies.
He actually believes in things like evolution.
So we're moving forward in the presidential
arena.
And I think that there are people around him
that I even know who can start having this
conversation.
And yes, people will yell back.
They yell back about everything.
But if we don't have it, we're just being
drowned out.
We're being drowned out right now by people
who actually think that creationism is this
-- 40 percent of the American people say
that, you know, we descended in our current
form 10,000 years ago.
That scares the hell out of me -- it really
does.
So, how do you do that?
You educate people.
And we don't do that very well.
We don't do it very well in school.
One of the things -- I don't say this in my
book but -- we should teach kids statistics.
We don't teach them statistics.
We teach them physics and chemistry, so for
some people, that's useful.
I'd much rather have my 16-year-old daughter
be able to go like this than to do experiments
with chemistry, which is something that I
have a feeling she won't be doing down the
road.
But we don't do it.
And it's really starting to take a toll on
our country.
You know, you can lose your edge.
You don't have to be the most advanced, technological
society forever.
There's lots of historical examples of countries
that have been advanced and have disappeared.
And that can happen to us.
And if you look at the education -- especially
math and science -- and you look at America,
say in '96, we are where we were 13 years
ago.
China? India? Hong Kong? Singapore?
I think Japan's good, but maybe not as good
as they were.
You can't stand still, and we are.
Q I share your concerns. Thank you.
Michael Specter: Thanks.
Q That segways really nicely into what I was
going to ask about.
So, it sounds like you think the one of the
problems we're facing is the decline in the
attractiveness of math and science to young
people.
Do you think that's a trend that we can reverse
in, you know, five years, ten years, twenty
years?
Michael Specter: I don't want to put a, "We
can do this in three years if we work really
hard" on it.
I just know that if we make the case that
our lives are dependent upon these things
-- and I actually think they are -- people
will respond.
I mean, we're not dumb in this country, and
we're really advanced and progress has defined
us.
And part of the problem is that we used to
believe in progress so blindly and foolishly
-- and have been let down a lot -- that now,
we kind of don't believe in it at all.
And I think that's sad.
But we can talk about that and get the word
out there.
I actually believe that or I wouldn't have
written this.
Thank you.
Q Yeah. This all moved into exactly what I
was going to ask about education and stuff
like that.
I sometimes wonder whether we should give
up on the current generation and just try
to engage our efforts into changing the education
of the next generation where we actually have
a better chance.
And along those lines or even if you think
we should still pay attention to the current
generation.
I mean, you wrote a book and that's great,
but I think you're preaching largely to the
choir here.
The question is, What are your practical -- I
mean, we agree I think a lot of us with what
you're saying, but do you have practical suggestions?
How should we actually make a case for change?
We're not all going to go off and write another
book and.
Michael Specter: I hope not, because my sales
will plummet if you do.
>> Exactly. So you know, practical suggestions?
Michael Specter: It's a really good question,
but I think that there are practical ways
to deal with each of these issues.
When someone tells you that they swallow antioxidant
formula D and vitamin E and vitamin C and
it makes them feel better and they know it
does, ask them why?
Ask them what they know about it.
Ask them did they see the study that says
actually it makes you sicker?
You know, echinacea is the second most used
herb in this country.
Everyone thinks if you take it, it will prevent
you from getting a cold.
Actually it doesn't help, and with little
kids, it just encourages respiratory infections.
So, it's going to seem silly, but I think
we just need to talk about these things.
I think we need to teach them.
And I think especially, you know, you say
'preaching to the choir', I'm surprised so
much on the food issue that I think I'm preaching
to the choir and I actually feel like I need
to have cosmetic surgery and move to Honduras.
Because you should see my e-mail.
And again, I think if people had a conversation
where they were told, "You know, your feelings
about multinational corporations may or may
not be serious and you might be right, but
that's not what this is about.
This is about a technology.
And we can use a technology in any number
of ways just as we can use vaccines in the
third world."
You know, in Africa, the rate of measles is
plummeting.
It still kills 300,000 people a year.
But the only place where it's growing is in
this country and Europe.
I mean, how shameful is that?
So I think these things have to be communicated
and they are.
And the media and the Internet are, I think,
partially to blame at least, I have to say.
We tend to scream at least as loudly as anyone.
Q I had a friend in grad school, a doctor
in computer science and then worked at NASA
and then, last I talked to her, she's become
a doctor of homeopathy.
Michael Specter: [Uh!]
Q How do you respond to that?
Michael Specter: I responded. [laughter]
Q How should I respond to that?
Michael Specter: I wrote about homeopathy
in my book.
So this is amazing.
I mean 'homeopathy' is the principle that
'like cures like'.
You could take like a little billionth of
a molecule of the thing that makes you sick
and dilute it and distill it and swallow it
and you'll be fine.
Now, any number of studies have shown this
to be complete and utter bunkum, but it doesn't
matter to people.
They still want it.
And I think sometimes they want it because
it seems real and comfortable.
And drugs don't seem real.
And they make you sick.
And by the way, we've been told that, you
know, we're going to have cancer cured and
this pill will take care of that.
And so often medicine isn't like that.
It's more an art than a science.
It doesn't banish things.
Sure, if you have strep throat, there's a
drug.
But often it's much more complicated and I
think we don't sell it that way.
And people get annoyed and then they go running
to something that seems comfortable.
Like homeopathy.
But woe, NASA to homeopathy. That's a bad
route.
>> [pause]
Q So one thing you haven't talked about very
much in your talk so far is religion.
Michael Specter: Yeah.
Q Do you think the fact that a lot of people
are indoctrinated from early age to believe
things that aren't proved or provable affects
their take on things later in life?
Michael Specter: Yeah. I try to duck the religion
thing as much as possible.
But I will say this.
I don't think that religion has to be in conflict
with science.
And there's lots of examples, including Albert
Einstein, to prove me right.
Yeah, there are fundamentalists -- Christians,
Jews, Muslims -- tons of people who are never
going to accept reality.
But most people are not like that.
And I don't see why a religion -- if people
feel good about religion and it gives them
some peace, I don't see why that has to interfere
with the scientific method and talking about
repeating studies, showing how they work,
showing what they do, and showing what happens
when you don't do them.
I may be utopian, but I don't think that is
the fundamental problem.
But it is something to think about.
Q So my knowledge of history is not that great,
but my impression is So Europe sort of went
through a transition a couple of hundred years
of sort of superstition to having a method.
Since then, a lot of other countries have
made that transition or are in
the process of transition.
Have you researched at all, How does that
transition happen?
You know, what's -- we have different cases,
because it happens in different kinds of places,
like different here than there?
Michael Specter: Well, it's a good question.
I think some of it is just level of education
and the number of people and the percentage
of people who are educated at a certain level.
But I would say this about Europe.
Yeah, they went through a transition a couple
hundred years ago.
I think they might be going through another
transition right now.
Because you say the word 'genetically modified
food' in that part of the world and you better
have a suit of armor.
And again, there are reasons for that because,
you know, they don't need genetically modified
corn or tasteless tomatoes, but their opposition
is so profound.
And the thing that kills me about that is,
So you're an environmentist and what do you
want?
Less water use? Less insecticide on the land?
Less energy used to get to crops?
These things can do that.
And actually the World Wildlife Fund has,
thank God, come out and said, "Gee, maybe
this biotechnology stuff is okay."
But I see it going in reverse in Europe actually
more rapidly than it's going in reverse here.
I don't know why they are okay with evolution
and we're not.
That's over my head -- above my pay rate.
But on the other stuff I don't think -- I
do see them moving backwards.
I see a lot of moving backwards.
Well, there may be a pendulum and that may
seem natural, but all I know is that, you
know, we used to die at the age of 40.
That was when we died.
It wasn't thousands of years ago.
It was 125 years ago, or 150 years ago.
And now, we die at the age of 80.
My grandfather died when he was 62, and that
was about 40 years ago.
And it was sad, but nobody said, "Oh, my God.
He was only 62," because you were supposed
to die when you're 62.
Well now, you're supposed to die when you're
82.
And people say when someone dies at 62, "Gee,
he got robbed of, you know, a bunch of life."
That's just in one generation.
That isn't 500 years.
So the advances we've made are just incredible.
And yet, we seem to be sliding backward in
the way we approach them, and, I think, part
of it is we take for granted what we have.
But for what it's worth.
Anything else?
Okay.
Go forth, plant genetically engineered food,
swear off organics, and thank you very much.
>> [Clapping]